BEN LITHGOW SMITH:
Deutsche Bank provides
a suite of products
and services across
retail and private banking,
corporate transaction banking,
lending, and asset
and wealth management.
DEEPAK SAREEN: So DevOps
and Cloud adoption
are part of our
technology transformation,
and the DevOps Research
and Assessment,
in short, the DORA
assessment, is key to this.
BEN LITHGOW SMITH:
And the business
challenges that we
face, really around cost
and also looking to increase
our in-house engineering
capability.
DEEPAK SAREEN: While we
previously relied heavily
on external
developers, we are now
strengthening our internal
engineering capabilities.
The key technology
goals for this project
were to reduce risk,
complexity, and cost
while supporting the
business innovation
and growth by
enabling new products
and services for our customers.
To this end, we are looking
to fully automate development,
deployment, and controls.
Enhanced DevOps practices
are central to this approach.
BEN LITHGOW SMITH: The
impact of these changes
started immediately and
improved steadily, particularly
for release frequency, which
rose from one release per month
in January 2021 to
three releases per month
by November 2021.
Stability also improved,
the number of incidents
declining by 40%
in the same time.
DEEPAK SAREEN: An
initial challenge
we faced was that the full
DORA assessment was being
re-platformed and
wasn't available,
so instead, we worked
closely with Google
to co-create a lightweight
assessment involving
approximately 50
participants across the band
to demonstrate the usefulness.
BEN LITHGOW SMITH: We then
selected an initial pilot area
for a full assessment,
and Googlers
were instrumental in helping
to select the granularity
to run that pilot
out and supporting
with initial briefings
and the result's debriefs.
We also had regular working
sessions with our partners
at Google as we scaled
things to workshop ideas
and plan next steps
together with a lot
of asynchronous collaboration
as well with Google partners
and the DORA team specifically.
The pilot gave us
great insights into how
we could run DORA at scale
across Deutsche Bank, which
we took into the first
full divisional rollout.
This also showed the need for
an option for teams too small
for the full
assessment, which led
us to develop and facilitate
a quick check along
with trying to train our
approach for scaling delivery.
We're really thankful to
receive this award from Google
and to all the teams who've
participated in the DORA
assessments across
the DB and have really
helped to facilitate real
transformational change.
We're also really thankful
for our Google partners,
both on our account and with
the Google DORA team as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]